نجم مصري شاب صاعد للقمه وبخطوات ثابته
ومن بعد مجموعه اعمال ناجحه منا مسلسل من
بطولته السنه الماضيه واعمال اخرى كثيره
كان دوروا فيها اساسي بيشارك احمد في
الموسم الرمضاني للعام بعملين الاول مسلسل
جعفر العمده اللي ماخذ اصداء واسعه
واشادات ويقوم في بدور سيف الشاب اللي
اساس نفسه بنفسه وبيكافح من عمره عشر
سنوات ولكن ما يعرف مين ابوه وكل ما يحاول
يعرف السر هذا امه ما بتقول له الحقيقه
المسلسل الثاني اللي بيقوم احمد داش
ببطوله في رمضان هو مسلسل الصندوق اللي
راح ينعرض في النصف الثاني من شهر رمضان
وهو من 15 حلقه وبتدور احداثه عند ثلاثه
اصدقاء بيوصلهم صندوق في ادله من جرائم
سابقه وبيبداوا رحله البحث الخاصه لحل
خيوط الجريمه او الجرائم والوصول لهويه
مرسل الصندوق الغامض
[موسيقى]
كل شيء بداخل الصندوق له معنى وليس عشوائي
اذا استطعت تفسير محتوياته فبامكانك ان
تنقذ روحين مين
في الصندوق هي اللي هتجاوب على الاسئله
اللي انت بتسالها
في حاجه زي كده في داهيه ما تسالش اسئله
اجابتها هتضرك واحد
البوليس احنا ماشيين بندور على عمال يقطر
الناس اللي عندها امراض خطيره دكتور ده
اكل عيش
وينضم الينا من القاهره النجم احمد داعش
اهلا يا احمد كل عام وانت بالف خير
اهلا اهلا يا ساره كل سنه وانت طيبه
ورمضان كريم علينا وعليك يا رب انا بس
حابه عندي احد حابب يسلم عليك معنا النجمه
مي كساب هي انتم ما جمعتكم الى الان اي
مشاهد في المسلسل ولكن هي موجوده معنا مي
اذا حابه تقولي لاحمد شيء او حابين انتم
الاثنين تكشفوا لنا اي سر
احنا لا يمكن
ضميرنا المهني ابدا طيب بس هتتلاقوا في
المسلسل لاحقا كيف كان الشغل معك الله
اعلم الله اعلم الله اعلم طيب اوكي خلاص
برافو عليك يا مي لانه التوقعات شغاله على
السوشيال ميديا على هذا الموضوع
دق جمهور الجمهور قاتلني من كومنتاته بجد
بيضحكوني بموت بالضحك واحمد انت اكيد جيتك
نفس التعليقات بتسالك على الموضوع
اه اكيد وهو وهو
محمد سامي نفسه هو كان قاصد اللي بيحصل
دلوقتي ده هو كان نفسه ان هو يحصل وهو
محضر له يعني الاسئله اللي بتتسال دلوقتي
هو كان قاصد ان يخلي الناس تسالها فده
حاجه لذيذه انك تشوف المكان المخرج نفسه
يحصل بيحصل دي حاجه جميله يعني
عشان تعرفي ان انت غاليه في مفاجاه في
حلقه بكره اهو حلو اهو خبر عشان خاطرك
طيب احنا بنشكرك واذا محمد سامي زعل منك
خليه يكلمنا نحن نعتذر منه
مفاجاه في حلقه بكره وبقول لاحمد داش الف
مبروك على الصندوق ومبروك على جعفر العمده
وهو عارف انا بحبه قد ايه وممثل شاطر
وموهبه كبيره اوي اوي مبروك علينا مبروك
علينا وطبعا يعني ما يكسب ولا انبسطت جدا
في الشغل معاها
كانت حلوه المسلسل كله بقينا عشنا
احمد انت هتفضل معانا ماي حابين نشكرك
شكرا جزيلا حبيبتي وبالتوفيق دائما في كل
اعمالك واشوفك الرمضان الجاي ان شاء الله
وانت منجمه اكثر هو اكثر كانت معنا ما
يتكسر شكرا لك
احمد خلينا نرجع الان
لشخصيتك في المسلسل اوزيف تحديدا خلينا
نتكلم اول شيء انه يعني في تكرار للتعاون
مع مع محمد سامي المخرج طبعا مخرج العمل
فيبدو انكم منسجمين كما هو واضح يعني
التعاون الثالث
وهو الحمد لله اه في يعني انا بفهمه وهو
بيفهمني بشكل كبير
والحمد لله يعني يا رب دايما نعمل الحاجات
الكويسه وتعجب الجمهور وتسليهم وتوصل
لاكبر عدد يمكن
واحده انك انت قلت انك انت هذه الشخصيه
فيها شبه منك تحديدا كيف فيها بالنكشبه
اكتر حاجتين كنت اشتغلت عليهم شبه بعض اهو
الشغل من سن صغير
انا وسيف اشتغلنا في نفس الوقت تقريبا انا
اشتغلت وانا عندي تسع سنين
وسيف المفروض بدا يشتغل بنفسه من وهو عنده
عشر سنين
فدي حاجه اشتغلت عليها والحاجه الثانيه
كانت
الكرامه يعني عندنا في مصر بنقول الكرامه
ناقحه عليه شويه ما يقبلش ان هو اي حد يقل
منه ولو
بحركه صغيره حتى يتحمل على طول ويغلي كده
زي مشهد
اه بالظبط بالظبط زي المشهد دهوت يعني
كرامته لقى عليه جدا جدا
انا يعني هو باين انه يعني السيف بيتحمس
في المواقف دي وفعلا كرامته بتنقح عليه هل
ممكن مثلا انت في موقف في الحياه مثلا
تضرب احد او تصرخ في احد عشان شيء زي كده
لا بس بغلي يعني مش مش هضرب ومش مش هاعلف
الموضوع يعني بس باغلي
بتضايق قوي لما حد يدفي على طرف
ربع سنتي بقى بتضايق
فاهماني
بفهمك جدا لانه انا من النوع اللي بيغلي
برده
في احد مين دخل عليك
القطه بتاعتي وكريم اخويا
احمد الان انت مو بس عندك هذا المسلسل انت
كمان كان عندك التجربه السنه الماضيه كانت
15 حلقه
ونجحت جدا كانت او نجح جدا المسلسل وقتها
ايوه اهلا وسهلا سوزي
سلمي يا سوزي خلينا الله
سلمي يا سوزي طيب سوزي كتكوته سوزي
اربع شهور
صغيره اوكي الوحيده اللي عندك ولا يبدو
عندك مجموعه لا الوحيد واحده بس طب وشك
انشكح يا احمد لما شفت سوزي
[ضحك]
ت اساريرك طيب يلا خلينا نتكلم معاك عن
الصندوق كنت بقول لك انه 15 حلقه السنه
الماضيه كان عندك تجربه نفس الشيء عجبتك
الفكره حقت 15 حلقه
والله حلوه
ودسمه ويعني الشغل فيها بيبقى
مروق اكتر
واقدر اقول مريح اكتر لان هي بتبقى عدد
حلقات اقل في
نقدر ناخد وقتنا في الكتابه بشكل اكبر لو
هندخل في نفس الوقت من الموسم الرمضاني
وبتبقى الحاجات يعني بحد كبير اروق وده
شفناه برده احنا السنه اللي فاتت كان اظن
احنا كنا مين قال 15 حلقه وما كانش في
اكتر من ثلاث اربع مسلسلات تانيه 15 حلقه
السنه دي في اكتر من ست مسلسلات 15 حلقه
ونجوم كبار عاملين العرض في النص الثاني
من رمضان بيظلم المسلسل اكثر او انه يعني
دي بتاعه ربنا بقى مش بقى يعني احنا السنه
اللي فاتت مين قالت عرض الجزء الاول ونجح
بشكل كبير الحمد لله وكان الجزء الثاني
فيه برضه مسلسل بتلو الروح بتاع
فانا بشوف الحاجات دي بتاعت ربنا يعني
سواء حتى كان اصلا بره رمضان يعني مش مش
بتاعتي مش بتاعه حد وكمان الدور في
الصندوق هيكون مختلف يعني شيء عاملينه زي
سيستم الستايل اللي هو الاجنبي يعني القصص
الاجنبيه البوليسيه
هو المسلسل واحنا
يعني بندور على
حد
والمسلسل في
تشويق بشكل كبير حتى الصوره هتكون مبينه
ده بشكل كبير
في عاليه والصوره حلوه والاخراج كويس يعني
متفائل به جدا ان شاء الله يكون مسلسل حلو
وهو مسلسل شبابي بشكل كبير ودي حاجه
بتحمسني دايما
اللي بيتابع
الادوار يعني نحن رحنا مثلا من
نستله لس
نه انقال انت طالب في الجامعه ومن عالم
مرتبه واول لا هناك كنت مثلا عايش انه في
الصعيد او في اي مكان زي ما سميته احنا مش
عارفين لسه او الان انت يعني كده طالع انه
ولد مو عارف ابوه بس في نفس الوقت ناجح
بسيط كمان يعني بتغير كثير يعني
يعني الحمد لله طبعا انا محظوظ بالادوار
اللي بتتعرض لي بان انا بقدر اختار
بشكل يريحني وبشكل اختار الحاجات اللي انا
احب اقدمها فالحمد لله بنشوف ان ده حظ من
عند ربنا ان انا اقدر اكون عندي الفرصه
اللي انا اختار واكيد بحب اختار حاجات
مختلفه عشان انا كمان اتبسط يعني اللي انا
بعمل ده وبعمل دهبت لنفسي ان انا اقدر على
ده واقدر على ده
احمد بهذا التنوع هذه الادوار الجميله بس
كنت بدي اسالك كمان سؤال سريع يا احمد انت
عندك اهتمامات متنوعه اصلا وعندك اهتمام
بموضوع المناخ حتى والتغير المناخي
والكلام هذا كله من وين جاء هذا الاهتمام
بهذا الموضوع وشاركت حتى في قمه المناخ
اللي صارت فيه مصر كمان
انا عشان انا انبسط اليونيسيفس بتاعتهم
اللي هي في مصر شباب بلد
اه مزبوط هي هي مبادره ما لهاش دعوه
بالمناخ هي ليها دعوه بالشباب والعمل
والشباب في مصر يشتغل ويقدر يدخل سوق
العمل بدون اي صعوبات عليهم زياده بس
المناخ دي دي مشكله عالميه بتمثنا كلنا
يعني مشكله المناخ دي مش هتاثر علي نكهه
احمد لا دي على العالم كله بشكل كبير
ومشكله لازم نلتفت لها قبل ما يعني قبل ما
تجيبنا كلنا الارض فاهماني
لو ما اهتميناش بها هيموتنا يعني الطبيعه
هتكسب اي حد ده طبيعي المفروض يعني قضيه
لازم نلتفت لها بشكل كبير ايوه صحيح لازم
تاخد حقها من تسليط الضوء عليها انا سعيد
دايما ان انا بتكلم معك يا احمد يعني
دائما تسعدني ادوارك وانت ما شاء الله
عليك ممثل موهوب ورائع جدا شكرا لكنك
مشاركتنا اليوم وان شاء الله دايما
بالتوفيق في علاقتك قصه حبك مع سوزي ان
شاء الله يعني تكبروا سوا ههه السنه
الجايه وهي سنه واربع شهور تكون ان شاء
الله فيعني
شكرا لك يا ساره واتشرفت بالمقابله دي
ودائما المقابله بتكون يعني والله انت
اللي وشك حلو عليا مش انا العكس وربنا
اللي فاتت يعني يا رب دايما نعملها عاده
وتكون سوزي كبرت بقى رمضان اللي جاي تيجي
معنا تتكلم
[ضحك]